there is a big fight at Staples coming
up this Saturday not airing on Fox
Sports PBC pay-per-view between the IBF
champion Errol the truth Spence jr. and
the man to my right the WBC champion
Showtime Shawn Porter 147 pound total
unification match good to see you
Showtime Shawn Porter it's about to go
down
interviewer okay that too okay My Mind's
on the fight we're gonna enjoy this
we'll have fun in there but yes you know
boxing is a sport mmm but a lot of times
it's like war and so we're about to go
to war in LA right here there's about to
be a war on US soil well if we are
talking about a battle like this yeah
then we need to talk a little bit of
tactics yeah and you sir are giving up
two inches in height two years in age
and almost three inches in reach what do
I have on my side well I'm just telling
my punch so so what are you what do you
would what the show Tom Shawn Porter
bring to the table
um yes sir I have a spirit to fight a
spirit of competition in my heart that
will drive me through anything through a
wall through a truck whatever I need to
do whatever is in my way I'm gonna go
through it obviously we with boxing you
have to be smart you just can't go out
there and throw anything you know we've
we've trained for arrow Spence we've
trained to be aggressive against arrow
Spence get to his body
obviously attacked the head as well
we've been training to be responsible we
defensively meaning when he throws his
his left hooks and when he throws his
his straight left's and things like that
we gotta be ready for all of that you
know so um the simple way for me to put
it and what I will tell arrow is you've
never been in the ring with someone who
has the combination that I have I'm
shorter than you are but I I can fight
big I can fight tall I can fight with
with range
I can box from the outside you have
never been in the ring with anyone as
aggressive as I can be and as relentless
as I can be and those are the things
that you should look for in the fight
and that's what I'm gonna use to pull
off this victory well I haven't been
fortunate to be around athletes for as
long as I have and and talk to the
athletes and fighters as well as an
athlete in athletic fighters like you
yeah that fire doesn't just come out
overnight no it's it's built and it's
stoked and you're you're born with it
yeah where does it come from and so yeah
things like you know you're born with it
okay and you still have to find a way to
figure it out and and and and hone in on
it so you talk about me being two years
older than DeNiro spends now I'm 31 and
you know I think normally this is where
guys start to kind of figure out you
know a all right I'm you know and you
know for me to stay young in the sport
for me to stay hungry in the sport we
did a lot of our training and DC and
people say why would you go to DC to
train what's down there for you right
there we have Barry hunter who is the my
dad sister to that assistant coach
Barry's got a lot of young guys in the
gym a lot of guys are even younger than
then arrow spins right what that youth
comes hunger and so when you look into
those guys eyes and you're competing
against those guys every day it really
does bring up your level of hunger and
and and and it has brung up my level of
desire not just to compete but to do
everything I have to do the B arrow
spins
I've got Showtime Shawn Porter here on
the Rich Eisen show the pride of Akron
Ohio along with LeBron James yeah word
word is LeBrons coming to this fight are
you hearing that we I did that's a ask
me a question yesterday I said you know
what I did not send a tweet I did not
send a DM or anything like that I sent a
text message and so I do believe that
he'll be in the building I know that his
close personal friend who I reached out
to is its maverick and MAV is a very
very big boxing fan so I anticipate
mavin and Brown being there and probably
though you know the whole crew well what
is it what is LeBron mean to that town I
mean you're from obviously so we hear
about it yeah and I actually have
somebody from that town I said to Chris
and I and
unfortunate to go to the Pro Football
Hall of Fame every single summer we're
on every day in Kent Ohio so I've seen
it and I know what it is but I'd love
for you to give voice to it a little bit
he's a hero um he is like Superman a guy
who has done everything that he could do
in his sport but also our side of this
sport for his City and surrounding areas
is remarkable for him to literally not
forget where he came from as remarkable
people right now he just opened up his
school back home yeah and and people are
doing the best that they can to get
their children into the program Rama
school yeah they even have things for
the parents the parents are trying to
get into that LeBron has made it
possible for our community to be a
community and I think before him nobody
everyone was out for their own I think
that he's shown that you can do what you
have to do for yourself but it's always
good to reach back and do that for
someone else as well so I believe that
he has made our community in Northeast
Ohio he's made it more of a community
than it's ever been
how does that inspire you it pushes me
to do what I've what I've tried to do
I've tried to be positive I've tried to
reach back and give back and to see
someone else doing it bigger than I am
you see that he's that it's in his mind
and his heart to do it lets me know that
it should never leave my mind or my
heart to do it so I go home as much as I
can to give back we do drives back home
in Vegas as much as we can and I'm
definitely looking forward to opening up
some nonprofits right after this fight
and get some things going for kids back
home as well as in Vegas Shawn Porter
here on the Rich Eisen show big Browns
fan huh
yeah gotta be man what's going on if
you're from Northeast Ohio you are a
Browns fan well two one and two is
definitely not what a lot of people
expected over the first three weeks here
with Odell and Baker and everybody
coming back from laughs the floor is
yours
you know take your time the canvas is
yours I'll go through it quick we got
the Titans the Titans have been together
for a while we're brand new teen we
still have to is that whole fill in our
process we get one of
drive and it goes our way all the way
down this does and I think that the
entire team expected on the rest of the
day to go that way I think once things
started to kind of go the opposite
direction I think that collectively the
team fell apart but the team has not
been a team together so nobody knew how
anyone was gonna react okay I think he
got two points where everybody was kind
of going on the limit just doing what
they thought thought that they should do
and you know we we dropped a game that
we thought we would win against the
Titans you know you come back against
the Jets and you know we show out when
we and we do a decent job I'm not gonna
say that you know I'm running that
football that was exactly the way we
should look on one on Monday Night
Football but it was it was a win for us
you know and Odell did what Odell needed
to do yeah I'm in it back in work where
his 85 yards huh he was he was amazing
yeah why don't we grab in the same
corner the end zone where he started his
hole yeah NFL branding my dad and I were
there at that game you were yeah and so
when he when he when he came out and I
saw him the way he was moving around the
field I was thinking to myself he played
for the Giants you didn't play for the
Jets but then I had to remind myself
they both play there so you could see
that there was a passion and in his mind
in his heart that night that he just
really wanted to make a statement all
night the visiting locker room for the
Jets is the Giants LA so we know that he
was hyped oh wow now that we know what
yeah
now also so I would have asked you if
I'd known you at the time was that your
advisor
no no they make him change it during the
game they made him change it here in
gold boy and he hated it yeah he hated
it yeah is that your watch it was
wearing - no definitely not that will
never be my watch now if you wanted you
know make a charitable comp you know
contribution to the team porter shawn
porter go ahead do what you want - hold
on
you win this fight everybody's talking
about it's possible you take on [ __ ]
yeah now then you can yeah now then the
watches come in no take that one down no
no no I got too much to do with what I
have did then to you know spend it on
that but okay you know let's say this
you know that his watch can feed a lot
of people watch his watch do a lot of
things for a lot of people for a lot of
years right so are you thinking right
now of unifying the weight class
entirely Yeah right yeah cuz it's been
since 2006 that that that's happened
that's not been done in Europe in your
welter weight Domingo from unification
to undisputed and right at the we we
take this belt from from eros pence
I think it makes sense that the next
stop is Manny Pacquiao Manny Pacquiao is
one of the greatest fighters to walk
this planet I've had the opportunity to
be in a few camps with him okay
and and spar with him I've done probably
50-plus rounds with him at least and to
have the opportunity to stand across
from him in the ring and actually go at
it with them I think would be not only a
remarkable for my team but I think it is
definitely something that the world
would would definitely appreciate as
well is this what you dreamed of what
you're doing I'll tell you what man what
I'm doing right now I have not dreamt of
this what this was not a dream what I'm
doing now is I'm living my goals and to
be in the moment living my goals is
unbelievable unbelievable how'd you get
the nickname Showtime my dad my dad gave
me the nickname shelter where did that
come from
he got it from a fighter that he watched
growing up when he was a young kid so
we're actually from Northeast Ohio my
dad is born and raised in Cleveland I'm
born in Cleveland spent half my life in
Cleveland the other half in the Akron
area right um my dad grew up in
Cleveland and he the place that he first
started boxing when he was about 10 he
said there was only one locker that had
a name on it at the light at the place
that he was at and the locker says
Showtime
and he said he watched that fighter
admired that fighter and the name just
kind of always stuck with my dad
gave me the name but the funny thing
about it is I think I've done and can do
everything that lives up to the name
Shelton was there any one specific
moment where your dad but still no dude
no like one time I just made my dad so
my dad is a promoter my dad is he's done
everything that you see me do is because
of him and when he started promoting me
on fights he we would go make the
posters with him we will make the
tickets cut the tickets sell the tickets
the whole nine and when he started
making posters for myself and my brother
he had to he had to give his nicknames
and that was where it all started mm-hmm
yeah well before he let you go to the
you're having a press conference later
today
yeah now when you go about your business
at this press conference yes sir show
time show yes sir and you're giving
Spence the business yes sir and you're
thinking yourself man I sound really
good and you're like you know what this
sounds better than most it's because our
sound engineer Mike del 2fo who's
normally in the chair we're yeah yeah
he's he's he's there today said he could
not be here today because he had to set
up for your press conference yeah which
is what about five six hours what your
press conference is the middle of the
afternoon diligent worker well I mean
that's well I mean can you hold up the
the the Fathead behind you so he can
know who to look for later on today
we're gonna hold up a Fathead version of
Mike Delta I'll take that you know what
please do that's him that's him I'll see
you later and if you don't if he if he's
not as sweaty yeah
later on today yeah just know what is
diligence like just dripping all over
all over him that's by the way that's
the name of his cologne is diligence
just reeks of diligence yeah but you'll
notice he'll have on these cargo shorts
yes that's all he that's all II wear and
then whatever move and then everything
else that he's wearing has been given to
him does not spend a dime on anything
right yeah if you see that guy tell him
we said hello okay I will and tell him
thanks for making me sound so good okay
I will
No yeah and and and how you how do you
think you sound over there you all right
no messing him um I think I sound just
fine yeah you sound great one of these
in oh yeah do one of those whoo yeah
how's that sound
I liked it I liked it one more one more
- in unison on three that sounds great
three record job Jay I have a three
record deal that come next time it's
gotta come from the diaphragm next time
I see you good luck to you man thank you
hopefully this is the first of many
times you see this man we're enjoying
all of this it's gonna be amazing
it's infectious you have an energy about
it Saturday's gonna be amazing you
really do yeah and I don't say that to a
lot of guests I feel that I sense it you
know maybe it's because Randall
Cunningham is your pastor yeah he's done
a tremendous job pastoring me and I do
need to get online with him as soon as
possible do you have you have his escape
ability as well did you have like is it
his his 100% yeah amazing yeah it's
amazing they're showing a photograph of
that right there
he's an amazing man amazing family
everything yeah he's one of the all-time
greats right that that play that you're
speaking on inmate the top 100 greatest
plays of yeah callbacks in the family
yes oh you weren't watching in a film
that works yeah yeah I always might all
of my TV's I think I have two TVs in my
house and they stay on the feel network
I knew we should get we get along yeah
that's I feel like a boxing fan so I'll
come back on and we'll talk boxing
because you know I'll be the champion
after now come back again talk football
okay yeah so later on this fall well
when your Browns are what six and three
take it easy on me
okay I just gave you five the next six
games is wins
okay so when that happens you come on
we'll talk sounds good to me okay that's
a Showtime Shawn Porter again you can
catch his fight with Errol the truth
Spence coming up on Fox Sports PBC
pay-per-view Saturday night from Staples
Center and later on today when you hear
his sound bites from his press
conference you'll go wow that's Mike
Dell two foes diligence work I do have
to say one more thing yes sir this fight
is gonna be aired at local AMC Theaters
and I think that that's amazing I'm a
movie buff I'm at the movies
all the time okay but I think the last
movie my dad and I just went to see was
it the chapter - yeah how many stars
would you give that uh that was that's
funny that you asked me because I used
to do that I gave it up about three and
three-quarter stars okay not about of
father five yeah it was not as good as
the first one best movie you've seen
lately then uh shoot not you now you got
me really gone um that spider-man the
last spider-man was really good and I
think the end of the indie game was
probably that's probably been the best
movie you and I should do with a movie
show together yes my last movie I saw
was the Downton Abbey movie yeah I used
to do a yeah I used to do an entire
thing when I would go to the movies I
would write as the movies ending I'd get
my whole synopsis on it and rain it and
all that kind of stuff and people look
forward to it but I stopped doing it
because when I would do it people would
just can't make boxing comments and I
was like you're not even talking about
what this what this post is about so I'd
stopped but I don't pigeonhole nobody
funny thing you are you who you are yeah
and I would give any movie a chance you
don't even know this but Jim Carrey did
a Polish movie he did a movie in Poland
did you know that I'm not aware of that
gave that movie a chance a whole two
hours at the end I was like why did I do
this
see that's a rating system yeah why did
I do that and then it goes up from there
oh man at Showtime Sean P on both
Twitter and Instagram for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app